on va revenir sur le le dénouement d'une
triste affaire qu'on va décrypter
l'acteur Marwan Beren connu pour son
rôle d'Abdel dans la série Plus belle la
vie était porté disparu depuis le 3 aût
dernier plus personne n'avait de ses
nouvelles pour rappel la nuit de sa
disparition la voiture qui lui
appartient à percutter une femme de 38
ans à Maon malheureusement on apprenait
vendredi que le corps du jeune homme de
34 ans aurait été retrouvé sans vie dans
une maison abandonnée on va recevoir
Michel Marie et on aura également Fiona
Fiona qui sera avec nous qui était très
proche de l'acteur qui va nous raconter
ce qui s voilà qu'il était réellement et
on les accueille juste après ce petit
récap et G j'aura une petite question à
à vous poser également c'est parti merci
r
merci depuis le 3 août dernier l'acteur
Marwan Beren qui était soupçonné d'avoir
renversé une femme au volant de son
véhicule avant de prendre la fuite avait
disparu des radars on a peur de ce qui
va se passer derrière surtout après
l'affaire panman ouais mais alors que
ses parents désespérés avaient décidé de
publier une lette ouverte dans la presse
reviens on a besoin de toi l'affaire a
connu jeudi soir un terrible
rebondissement avec la découverte d'un
corps sans vie dans le rô les premiers
éléments laissent penser qu'il s'agirait
de son corps une information confirmée
dans la foulée par le magazine Paris
Match qui a déclenché une vague dommage
alors est-ce bien le corps de l'acteur
dans quelles circonstances a-t-il été
retrouvé quelles sont les pistes
envisagées découverte d'un corps qui
serait celui de Marwan Beren que
s'est-il
passé merci Fiona merci d'être là ça
nous fait Pla de revoir on aurait vous
pvoir dans dans dans voir dans d'autres
circonstances mais bon on est voilà
merci en tout cas d'être avec nous
Michel Marie avec nous également euh
journaliste bien entendu pouvez-vous
nous raconter ce qui s'est passé euh
Michel Marie depuis le début et dans
l'enquête puisque là ça y est euh on a
on a malheureusement nos réponses et
elles sont tristes je commençais par la
fin c'est-à-dire le 12 jeudi dernier
euh ça se passe dans un tout petit
village qui s'appelle corsel en
beaujelet il y a une maison un peu
abandonnée un corps de ferme et le
propriétaire plus précisément le fils du
propriétaire arrive ce jour-là dans
l'après-midi avec des des artisans pour
envisager de faire un un un chantier
enfin de faire une rénovation de ce
bâtiment et il pénètre à l'intérieur du
bâtiment et découvre dans une pièce dans
la pénombre il distingue un corps des
chaussures et immédiatement il sort
prévient les gendarmes qui arrivent sur
place et après avoir fait leur travail
de constatation s'aperçoivent que c'est
très très probablement à 99,9 % Marwan
berenny tout ça parce qu'il y a une
d'abord parce qu' on est à 3 ou 4 km de
l'endroit où il avait abandonné sa
voiture donc là c'est fleur hein le long
d'un champ de vigne il a dû couper à
travers les vignes pour rejoindre
corsel et les gendarmes découvrent une
banane dans laquelle se trouve permis de
conduire carartes d'identité et d'autres
documents qui au nom donc de Marwan
Beren et tout ça a commencé le 3 août
euh aux alentours de enfin pas aux
alentours à
23h10 Marwan berenny était dans une
boîte de nuit qui s'appelle le 400 le
club 400 à Macon eu il est pas resté
longtemps ce soir-là il était tout seul
il a bu un verre il a eu deux appel
téléphonique il est resté une demi-heure
et ensuite il est ressorti on l'a en
vidéosurveillance à 11h5 23h05 euh il il
monte dans cette voiture ce fameux 4x4
Mercedes il démarre sur lescha paaurou
et au même moment une jeune femme de 37
ans traverse dans les passages protégés
les passages cloutés euh elle est avec
son chien et elle est littéralement
percutée par le véhicule qui n'a pas
freiné et qui ne s'est surtout pas
arrêtter et à partir de là on on on sait
pas très bien ce qu'il a fait je pense
qu'il est il a dû rentrer dormir chez
lui il habitait à Fuissé
euh le lendemain on sait par ça carte
bleue qu'il a utilisé dans une
boulangerie je crois à 15h et il aurait
passé un appel téléphonique à
13h38 c'est les derniers signes de vie
qu'on a de Marwan Beren ensuite il se
volatilise le 5 août donc 2 jours après
on retrouve la Mercedes sur le bord de
de la route et le 12 donc jeudi dernier
on retrouve mais il y a plein de
questions parce que qu'on que doivent se
poser les les téléspectateurs également
comment il s'est retrouvé dans dans
cette maison c'était une maison
abandonnée comment il s'est retrouvé là
on comprend pas ça on sait pas il y a un
couple qui témoigne et qui dit l'avoir
vu Erer au lendemain dans les dans les
vignes autour donc est-ce qu'il s'est
déplacé à pied c'est à 6 km de là la
voiture de voiture voilà est-ce qu'il
est parti à pied vers cette maison et
dans un geste de désespoir voilà là pour
le moment on ignore mais mais ce qu'on
comprend pas et chez vous on va on va
reprendre l'affaire c'està-dire que il
percute cette jeune fille donc en boîte
de nuit donc donc derrière en sortant de
boîte de nuit le soir là il prend sa
voiture
et pourquoi il met fin à ses jours alors
qu'il a dû avoir des nouvelles comme
quoi cette jeune fille euh quelques
jours après allit voilà elle était
blessée mais voilà elle s'en elle s'en
était sorti c'est ça c'est ça qu'on
comprend pas
euh c'est on comprend pas en fait non
non je je pense pas qu'il est au moment
où bah il a éta à la boulangerie donc un
moment oui non mais c'est c'est le
lendemain matin et le lendemain matin on
bah si le lendemain matin on savait si
si si bah si le lendemain matin
lendemain matin je suis désolé vous
savez si une personne est décédée ou pas
si vous l'avez si vous l'avez percuté he
en tout cas elle était dans le comma ses
jours étaé elle était en pronostic vit à
l'engager d'accord Sandra à qui on pense
fort aussi bien bien sûr euh donc je
pense que c'est pas aussi simple que ça
et et je pense qu'il
a de toute façon ça devait enfin c'est
c'est très compliqué de commenter un
suicide de de de c'est quelquefois même
un peu indécent donc moi ça me enfin ça
me me dérange mais il a c'est jamais une
cause unique un suicide euh donc il y a
l'accident on sait aussi qu'il y avait
son son frère c'était un peu la date
anniversaire de la mort de son frère
Bilal qui lui a été assassiné à D3 aux
États-Unis euh en 2013
euh d'accord mais euh si vous vous le
connaissiez bien moi je le connaissais
bien ouais je le connaissais bien
j'avais passé on a été très proche
pendant quelques mois voilà on a eu on a
eu une histoire et puis ça faisait quand
même des années que je l'avais pas vuord
j'avais toujours de ces nouvelles parce
qu'on a des amis en commun et et voilà
c'était c'était un super garçon c'est un
c'est un artiste justement comment après
avoir percuté cette jeune fille il il
peut partir et dire parce que c'est
c'est extrêmement violent il se seraité
pendu c'est çaag oui c'est ça oui oui
absolument le le le corps qui a été
retrouvé é été retrouvé pendu avec des
papiers à son nom donc voilà il y a une
autopsie mais voilà c'est à 99 % lui
hélas et sans
doute ne pas pouvoir accepter ce qu'il
vient de faire en se disant j'ai commis
l'irréparable j'ai commis un acte
horrible c'est insupportable pour moi et
donc voilà je je ma ma vie est ma vie
est fichue j'ai brisé une vie peut-être
et je ne peux plus m'accepter comme ça
parce que tout à l'heure je vous voyais
me faire des signes vous me disez il
savait pas qu'il savait pas le lendemain
quand il va à la boulangerie qu'on
allaito mais non le lendemain en fait la
la la jeune femme Sandra elle est en
réanimation et on sait pas si de quelle
manière elle va s'en sortir en fait et
quand il a ce ce dernier appelle à
13h38 on sait toujours pas si si sandra
est vivante si Sandra bah voilà dans
quelle est aller et et je sais que à
13h38 et il le dit je sais pas si c'est
un truc que je dois dire mais il le dit
la seule chose qui me reste à faire
c'est partir quoi donc il le dit à
13h38 dernier appel c'est des choses qui
m'ont été répété donc j'ai pas je peux
rien vous qui il donne son dernier appel
on peut pas savoir on sais pas voilà
un c'est le dernier appel qu' donne et
dans son dernier appel a priori il
dirait la seule chose qu' me reste à
faire c'estette partir donc c'est
vraiment suite à à cet accident que il
décide de de de de mettre fin s j mais
je parle en son nom mais Marwan il
vivait avec la culpabilité de la mort de
son frère même s'il y est pour rien mais
en fait ne pas réussi enfin ne pas avoir
réussi à protéger son petit frère enfin
je pense que c'était c'était déjà inv
viiva pour lui c'était quelqu'un de
torturé quelqu'un de tourmenté quelqu'
c'était il vivait sans limite moi
c'était un pour moi c'était un artiste
qui était beaucoup plus intelligent que
tout le monde et je pense que personne
pouvait être dans son cerveau et là le
fait d'avoir bah voilà renversé
quelqu'un je pense que c'était bah
c'était la petite goutte d'eau qui qui
qui a fait déborder qui a fait déborder
le grosse gout d'eau oui et oui la mort
de son frère est fondamentale Cyril pour
pour comprendre on va rappeler on va
rappeler pour téléspectateurs s'appelait
comment son joaim sonre son frère
c'était un graffeur Bilal voilà très
connu qui notamment avait fait des
grafes au moment du du printemps arabe
et pour célébrer les martyres Tunis et
qui qui qui était connu dans le milieu
du Graf voilà il est à D3 aux États-Unis
et là il est pris à parti par trois
personnes qui le tue d' une balle dans
la tête ces trois personnes avaient des
dettes et voulaient le dévaliser lui ont
pris 200 ou 300 € sans le connaître il
était près d'un terrain de basket ils
l'ont tué sauvagement et au-delà du pire
du pire c'est que son corps a mis 8 mois
à être identifié pendant 8 mois il a
disparu on ne savait pas que c'était lui
donc du coup ça a été voilà pour lui un
un drame épouvantable et c'est vrai
qu'il y avait une certaine fragilité
mais mais mais c'est normal c'est
tellement épouvantable ce drame que que
voilà il avait vraiment du mal c'est
impossible de digérer ça mais pour lui
c'était très très dur mais vous avez dit
qu' qu'il avait peut-être été vu en
Suisse alors c'est ça parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ont réagi ce
weekend ont dit g disait qu'il était en
Suisse alors que pas du toutou voilà
alors ça donc ce qu'il faut dire c'est
que nous quand on couvre des des des
faits divers et des enquêtes on avance
au rythme de l'enquête d'accord et un
média extrêmement crédible qui jusque là
Ava eu toutes les bonnes informations a
révélé cette piste Suisse qui a été
reprise par d'autres médiia moi j'ai
travaillé avec ce média puis j'ai
vérifié et à ce moment-là quand on en a
parlé ici il y avait l'hypothèse de
cette piste Suisse sur laquelle la
police travaillait voilà hypothèse qui
n'est donc pas avérée je ne cite pas le
média en question je vais en prendre la
responsabilité voilà mer bra gin voilà
hypothèse qui ne s'est pas avéré mais
qui était à l'époque jugé extrêmement
crédible par la police voilà alors euh
Michel donc l'histoire donc qu'est-ce
qui s'est qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
parce que il a on l'a pas retrouvé
pendant des jours et des jours oui c'est
ça qu'on a envie de savoir parce qu'on
comprend c'est ça qu'on comprend pas
donc racontez-nous pendant 2 mois on
sait pas où il est donc qu'est-ce que
c'est Passi la police était chargée de
l'enquête et ils ont été à son domicile
ils ont convoqué un certain nombre de de
proches de Marwan pour essayer de savoir
s'ils avaient des nouvelles ils ont
essayé de remonter aussi les la télé
téonie mais en même temps il il pouvait
pas fouiller toutes les maisons à 10 15
km aux alentours de de son domicile ils
sont donc en réalité si le fils du
propriétaire était pas venu ce jour-là
pour faire faire des des devis avec les
artisans je pense qu'on aurait toujours
pas retrouvé le le corps de Marwan
berini alors et les enquêteurs ont mis
longtemps à démarrer plus au début il
pensait au-delà de ça oui tu as raison
mais au-delà de ça techniquement c'est
impossible qu'il fouille toutes les
maisons c'est pas c'est pas mais ce qui
frappe Michel c'est 5 km 6 km donc on se
dit quand même quelqu'un disparaî on
peut faire des cercles concentriques et
voà il est daté à quand son décès bah
c'est ça ouai il est daté à quand son
décès pas ça on a pas la date mais enfin
sans vouloir entrer dans les détails
c'était à mon avis très proche vu le
l'état du corps c'était donc très proche
de de sa disparition très vite après son
dernier coup je P hntement que il a
abandonné sa voiture il a traversé les
vignes à pied il est rentré dans ce
bâtiment est- qu'il le connaissait
est-ce qu'il est rentré par par hasard
trou trouver une maison abandonnée c'est
compliqué la connait et donc c'était
quoi et donc après et là il se pend
c'est c'est fou donc c'est jamais fi en
fait il a jamais fui en fait pas supp
fait a priori on dirait avec des des des
des S avec conditionn ce serait vraiment
juste le lendemain c'est ça de la faire
comme vous le disiez il y a un instant
donc dernier coup de fil à 13h38 et
derrière le le drame Fiona il y a
datanie marqu qui éta avec nous qui
était avec avec lui en vacances quelques
jours avant le le drame il lui avait dit
moi si un jour je renverse quelqu'un je
me foutrai en l'air je ne le supporterai
pas et je ne veux pas avoir ça sur ma
conscience bah moi vous savez c'est
c'est paradoxal avec le petit message
qu'il avait laissé à 13h30 mais moi
j'étais persuadée j'aurais mis ma main à
coup que ce soirl que j'ai rencontré
Maran j'aurais mis ma main coupé que que
qu'il avait fui et que on l'aurait
retrouvé dans 5 5 ans 10 ans j'aurais
jamais pu imaginer qu'il met fin un sé
jour et quand je lis la lettre de ses
parents le 3 octobre si je dis pas de
bêtises je pense que ses parents étaient
incapables de s'imaginer qu'il pourrait
qu'il pourrait faire une chose pareille
mais moi je croyais j'étais sûr que
franchement c'est c'est inimaginable
etfin horrible quoi les de vous avez dit
il a passé un dernier coup à 138 et il a
annoncé mien faireou oui oui mais entre
annoncer et le faire vous savez cy je
sais bah bien sûr non non mais c'est sûr
et c'est c'est il faisait est-ce que il
faisait référence à l'accident de Pierre
Palmade oui bien sûr ah d'accord même
dans son dernier coup de fil non enfin
dans le le témoignage que vous é bien
sûr il a dit s' m' arriva quelque chose
comme Pierre Palmade je je je mettrai
fin à mes jours Fiona vous qui le donc
vous qui le connaissez bien Fiona vous
vous êtes dit quoi parce que disparition
pendant 2 mois est-ce que avec vos vos
amis proches avec les gens qui
connaissaient Marwan vous êtes appelé
vous êtes dit qu'est-ce qu'il a est-ce
que tu as des n fait moi pour vous
raconter c'est simple le dans la nuit du
3 au 4 il se passe cet accident dans là
et le 4 au soir j'ai un appel donc la
presse est pas encore au courant je sais
pas si les parents sont déjà au courant
j'ai un appel voilà il y a eu une soirée
il s'est passé ça ça ça ouais ouais une
amie il s'est passé ça ça on sait pas si
c'est lui il y a des VI passé quoi parce
que il s'est passé quoi ben il s'est
passé qu'il était à une soirée il est
parti parce que bah il avait sans doute
bien profité et que il avait envie
d'aller faire la fête en boîte il va en
boîte là il prend sa voiture à ce
moment-là quand on m'appelle le 4 août
on sait pas si c'est lui il y a des
vidéos de Caméra surveillance mais on
sait pas encore si c'est lui et notre
ami me dit Fiona on sait pas où il est
depuis depuis hier il donne plus de
nouvelle à personne il a passé un
dernier appel mais depuis son son
téléphone ne fonctionne plus il est
coupé on sait pas où est sa voiture on
est allé chez lui il est pas chez lui
donc moi je sais depuis 4 depuis le 4
août et depuis le 4 août on se dit et on
s'appelle régulièrement on se voit et on
se dit mais c'est sûr en fait c'est sûr
il est parti il a un compli vous savez
on
imagine chose quand il est parti de
cette première soirée il est allé en
boîte de nuit tout seul oui d'accord
donc c'est ça donc c'est lui qui était
donc au volant de la voiture à priori
Michel hein par que c'est une question
qu'on se posait bien sûr non mais
d'après les témoins il passe une
demi-heure dans cette fameuse boîte de
nuit le le club 400 il reçoit deux
appels téléphoniques de ça je sais pas
de qui il est très bref dans ses
communication téléphonique je pense
qu'il a vraiment envie d'être tranquille
d'être tout seul et il reste une
demi-heure et il s'en va donc il est pas
venu faire la fête il a il a bu un verre
et il remonte dans sa voiture et là il y
a de la vidéosurveillance à la sortie de
la boîte de nuit il est 3h05 il monte
dans son véhicule et l'accident est à
23h10 c'est ça et derrière ça va très
vite et derrière plus de nouvelle oui F
derrière non derrière plus nouvelle
derrière dernière nouvelle à 13h30 et
puis quand il va à la boulangerie je
crois acheter à 15h à 15h quelque chose
mais après derrière rien la personne qui
vous a dit qu'à 13h38 il l'a appelé et
il lui a dit la seule chose qu' me reste
à faire c'est de de mettre fin à mes
jours est-ce qu'elle a essayé de de
faire quelque chose de prévenir je sais
pas franchement je sais pas je sais que
tout le monde lui a dit euh les gens qui
ont essayé de l'appeler leors soit par
message ou voilà lui ont dit écoute il y
a rien encore il y a pas de preuve on
sait pas viens si c'est toi on sera là
on t'aidera et et au même titre que le
message de ses parents euh tu sais une
épreuve on la partage et on la vit
ensemble et on la surmonte ensemble vous
lui avez laissé un message non non moi
j'ai pas laissé de message moi j'ai pas
laissé de message parce que j'avais on
fait chacun nos vie de notre côté et
puis et puis voilà on n pas toujours
besoin d'avoir des nouvelles d'un
excomagnon mais non ça faisait combien
de temps que c'était fini is ça faisait
un moment ça faisait quelques années
d'accord et vous toujours des nouvelles
exactement c'était et personne euh dans
son entourage dans vos amis puis que
vous étiez une bande d'amis voilà vous
aviez des amis en commun et vous étiez
une bande d'amis personne ne se disait
qu'il pouvait commettre les LIR par mais
je pense pas et je voyais alors moi je
connais pas tous ses amis mais je pense
notamment à David baot qui était un de
ses meilleurs amis qui est acteur Dounia
et bon voilà ils avaient l'air de faire
leur vie et je pense que vraiment
personne pouvait imaginer qu'il
metettent fin un séjour personne
vraiment personne c'est c'est c'est trop
brutal trop brutal c'est oui g c'est une
période où son entourage dit qu'il
allait mieux il y avait eu l'arrêt de la
série très dur pour lui mais là il avait
un rôle encore majeur dans la série qui
va d'ailleurs recommencer très bientôt
donc voilà il était plutôt mieux il
refaisait du sport et voilà donc ce qui
s'est passé à cette soirée et et après
l'accident a été le déclencheur de
quelque chose y a pas mal de gens qui
disent il a tout de suite pensé il
aurait tout de suite pensé à laaffaire
Pierre Palmade il en parlit en plus
beaucoup et c'est ça aussi qui qui s'est
dit je ne veux pas être dans une dans un
tel marasme c'est ça une fois de plus
c'est qu de de se mettre dans la tête de
quelqu'un qui qui commet l'irréparable
mais le le décès de son frère qui
remontait à 10
ans lui posait un véritable problème
enfin c'était c'est quelque chose qui le
tourmentait
énormément et c'est vrai qu'il allait
mieux c'est vrai qu'il s'est terminis à
faire du sport tous les jours tous les
deux jours il partait courir il rentrait
de vacances je crois qu'il était parti
aux Philippines où il est passé quelques
jours en en vacances et il y avait cette
cette perspective de de travail mais ça
ne suffit la preuve d'ailleurs ça ne
suffit pas
pour pour éviter cette catastrophe
et quand
on je je pense que le lendemain il ne
savait pas je je maintiens je pense
qu'il ne savait pas le lendemain dans
quel état se trouvait la victime
et comme il allait pas très bien quand
même dans dans sa tête il s'est il s'est
il s'est fait sans doute son son son
film en se disant j'ai j'ai tué cette
femme ma carrière est finie je vais
aller en
prison et je pense qu'il s'est fait un
scénario catastrophe qu'il a peut-être
pas trouvé à ce moment-là la bonne
personne au téléphone pour lui dire bon
allez arrête on va aller au commissariat
on va on va s'expliquer et effectivement
tu auras des ennuis
mais pourquoi [__] sa vie en l'
c'est un accident c'est fou ouais c'est
fou parce que il là il panique après le
et là tout tout tout çaaccélère alors on
a mis quand même de mois à retrouver le
corps à priori oui alors oui on a mis de
mois à retrouver le corps mais ce que je
disais tout à l'heure euh la police elle
peut pas fouiller dans toutes les
maisons c'est c'est c'est pas oui Ron
bah c'est pas toutes les maisons on a
parlé d'une ferme abandonnée ouais donc
tu peux au moins aller fouiller un truc
qui a abandonné que tu dis peut-être
qu'il a été se caché là-dedans moi je
suis jeis la police a vraiment cherché
44 tu le caches pas comme ça
c'est le 44 il était sur le bord la
route il était à combien de kilomètres
de 5 km donc 5 km moi je sais si à 5 km
de chez moi il y a une maison abandonnée
je le sais je suis au courant donc la
police devrait devait savoir ça que
c'est abandonné petite
anance technique c'est la police de
Macon qui est saisie de l'affaire euh et
là on est en zone rurale où normalement
c'est les gendarmes qui travaillent sur
ce ce genre de de de chose donc euh
la police de Macon je pense qu'il ils
ont pas tourné oui je suis d'accord si
tu appelles une police qui a 200 bornes
une fois de plus non c'est pas 200
bornes mais c'est une vingtaine de km et
une fois de plus
euh ils ont fait leur travail c'est
qu'ils ont vérifié auprès des amis la
téléphonie enfin ils ont fait le travail
des enquêteurs qui qui qu'il fallait
faire euh et bon c'est voilà en tout cas
voilà je voudrais qu'on vienne parce
qu'on est en temps direct 21h13 et euh
un drame vient de se passer euh à
Bruxelles euh